[Music]
you plan to be cryogenically frozen
I said well you did my show dinner with
the Kings yeah I was a great one of the
great shows yeah yes and you were
shocked at that I was shocked that you
want to be cryogenically frozen well
here why okay I don't believe in an
afterlife I can't I just never accepted
it I never made that leap of faith so
that means when you die it's byebye baby
right right
lights out goodbye goodbye so the only
hope the only fragment of hope is to be
frozen and then someday they cure
whatever you died of and you're back so
in other words you put me in the ground
or you burn me up with it that's you
don't want that I want to have a I'm
Jewish
we gotta have hope I got a heaven if I
have a fragment of hope my wife is oh I
thought you were saying you want to be
frozen at this side I wanna be made real
small and then frozen so putting
someone's drink my wife
why do I come here why does anybody come
here my wife is a devout Mormon yeah she
is totally opposed to this and I said
look I know you like to control things
yeah but I can't I can't die the way I
want to die yeah and so I that's it so I
want to pay attention when I go yeah I
want to be frozen well why are you
putting the responsibility on me now
I've got to go busting in his hospital
wherever the stadium wherever you are
I gotta go busting in its everybody back
I'm taking them to the freezer you know
if are the presumption that you don't
believe there's anything after it right
why is it stupid I would say it's to
give me another give me one attack the
thing I always think about is okay they
freeze you all right then they unfreeze
you and then they get you going again at
some point you got to go right but wait
a second at least you have another
chance and like what if by that time
whatever you just want you just want to
have yet another TV show what are they
what is your 30 years from now you come
cracking out of the ice and go it's
Larry King I live
alright why is that bad not a bad idea
I'll be right there with you yeah head
in a jar flow on my wife says to me well
your first guest my wife says to me it's
stupid you won't know anybody I said
I'll make new friends yeah have your
whole body frozen well as to I just
there's a new book out called the kid
the story of Ted Williams yeah and the
whole first chapter by Ben Bradley jr.
is about he was cryonics yeah yeah and
there's two ways you could do it you
could do the whole body or they cut off
the head and put the head aside and then
attach it to a different body you know
what I want it sounds weird I want I
want a different body now I would like
this head put on like in a great body
now wow you have a great body hello what
did you notice that I noticed it Conan
when you did the little walk off there
with that crazy bit with the Russian guy
with yeah yeah you know yeah you know
folks that wasn't in Russia now look
what you did I hate that was a real guy
and a real bear I sort of a guy walking
off with his bare head off he's going
off to freeze it yeah
what else watch the second chance this
is not PBS